la course aux oscars est lancé et c'est
joker de todd phillips qui part en pole
position avec 11 nominations
il est rare qu'on donne ce genre de prix
meilleur film un film qui effectivement
orales y ait autant de spectateurs
avec dix nominations chacun dia rachwane
de martin scorsese i il était une fois à
hollywood the queen teen tarantino 1917
de sam mendes promettent de lui livrer
une chaude lutte
ils sont tous nommés pour meilleur
réalisateur et l'absence de femmes dans
cette catégorie risque par ailleurs de
faire sourciller il y avait des choix
possibles qui n'ont pas été fait et je
pense que ça risque d'être souligné
aussi pendant la cérémonie elle même les
jeux sont faits avec 10 h même une
histoire de mariage et deux papes c'est
une très bonne récolte pour netflix qui
décrochent 24 nomination à qui il faudra
voir si contrairement à ce qui s'est
produit à la cérémonie des golden globes
ces nominations se traduiront en
statuettes on sait que netflix dans les
années à venir va probablement s'emparer
d'une grosse part du gâteau de
l'industrie hollywoodienne donc est ce
que ça se jouera cette année
probablement en appeler de wifi
maintenant le film sud-coréen parasites
fait bonne figure avec six nominations
se retrouvant à la fois dans la
catégorie meilleur film international et
meilleur film tout court c'est le film
cendrillon dans tout ça c'est un peu le
roman de cette année saisir un film qui
n'est pas langue anglaise mais qui
s'affirme dans plusieurs catégories
et selon nos experts qui sont les grands
favoris j'ai l'impression que ça se joue
entre martin scorsese et quentin
tarantino je pense que c'est vraiment
les deux films phares de cette année est
bien sûr l'année brad pitt parce
qu'enfin il remportera une scarlets vous
entendrez des violons pendant
les semaines qui suivent un tel choix
côté canadien
le film pro de goode est retenu dans la
catégorie meilleur court métrage de
fiction c'est faux c'est ce réel
c'est ça on n'y crois pas encore on
commence à y croire mais ça reste une
très très belle surprise
je rappelle quand j'étais petit je sais
tu rêves mes congés condijts hélas tombé
maintenant c'est c'est pour ça c'est un
peu fou c'est surréel
c'est le 9 février qu'elles sauront si
le rêve de remporter un oscar devient
réalité ici n'a dit alexandre chartier
radio canada montréal